ravi de vous retrouver sur les chaînes
parlementaires pour vous présenter la
saison 3 d'europe hebdo nous sommes
comme toujours à strasbourg au coeur du
parlement européen et oui katia et pour
cette nouvelle saison nous reviendrons
comme d'habitude sur les grands dossiers
qui marquent l'actualité européenne
cette semaine c'est la crise agricole
qui a secoué l'été pourquoi les
agriculteurs français accusent leur
homologues espagnols de concurrence
déloyale
nous avons été enquêté au sud de
l'espagne est d'abord l'actualité la
question palestinienne divise l'union
européenne c'est la question de la
semaine
à la tribune des nations unies mahmoud
abbas a ressuscité quelques instants
yasser arafat ennemis la communauté
internationale au pied du mur
reconnaître la palestine comme un état
ou pas depuis l'annnonce on s'agite dans
les couloirs de la diplomatie mondiale
au conseil de sécurité de l'onu on
examine la demande rudi c'est qu'on
tergiverse
objectif éviter le drame et l'enlisement
il faut neuf voix sur quinze et les
etats unis menacent d'opposer leur veto
et après des mois de silence le
quartette composé des états unis de
l'europe de la russie et des nations
unies presse le leader palestiniens à
reprendre les négociations
encore et toujours des négociations sans
concertation avec ses homologues
européens
nicolas sarkozy lui plaide pour une voie
médiane statut d'état observateur comme
le vatican la palestine un futur vatican
du prochain encan
dans les coulisses ça grince on s'irrite
une fois de plus de l'initiative
personnelle du président français qui a
tracé une belle fissures dans la fragile
unité de façade de l'union européenne
sur le dossier
empêtré acculé reconnaître ou pas se
mettre à dos les peuples les arabes tout
frais sortis de leur printemps
démocratique braquer israël et son allié
américain
diviser l'europe tiraillé entre les pays
pro israéliens comme la république
tchèque l'allemagne ou les pays-bas et
les pro palestiniens comme l'espagne
l'autriche ou la france
kafkaïen alors c'est cool quand cet état
policier
voilà la question de l'état palestinien
qui divise donc la communauté
internationale et notamment l'europe
nous avons été rejoints sur ce plateau à
strasbourg par véronique de kaiser
bonjour je vous êtes eurodéputés belges
près vice-présidente des députés
socialistes au parlement est en charge
de la politique extérieure et vous êtes
allé plusieurs fois à gaza notamment
lors des élections organisées en 2009
alors dit nous on voit bien que l'europe
était divisée aujourd'hui sur cette
question quelle est la position du
parlement européen que vous représentez
oui je suis allé pour les élections de
2005 pour miner la présidence de
damas et j'étais chef de la mission
d'observation 2006 quand la masse a pris
le pouvoir et depuis je suis allé
plusieurs fois par an la base est la
position du parlement
si on la compare à celle des
gouvernements européens est une position
historique
je pense nous nous prononçons pour
soutenir la demande de du président
abbas c'est une position partagée par
vos collègues de différents horizons
qu'il ya une sorte d'unanimité au
parlement pour c'est une position et
c'est pour ça que c'est historique c'est
une position qui était signée par tous
les grands partis à votre initiative
c'est vous qui avait été à l'origine de
on est plusieurs à six et demi dans
chaque partie vous savez depuis
longtemps au parlement je ne dirais pas
ce qu'ils sont pour la palestine et ceux
qui sont pour israël c'est faux il ya
ceux qui ont été dans la région et ceux
qui n'y ont pas été et je pense que ça
fait une différence
absolument fondamental je vais vous
prendre un exemple
l'ex-président du parlement européen
monsieur patrick allemand
démocrate-chrétien grand ami d'israël
quand il est allé là bas qu'il a vu
l'état des conditions de vie des
palestiniens est revenue absolument
transformer en se battant aussi pour ça
donc vous avez eu des tas de délégations
qui sont partis et à chaque fois sa
forme il n'a finalement à un groupe qui
est conscient des des problèmes alors le
parlement européen au moins ça s'exprime
à haute voix sur cette question ce n'est
pas le cas des autres dirigeants
européens finalement on a vu qu'un seul
nicolas sarkozy qui est venu à la
tribune de l'onu pour proposer son
initiative
son statut accordé un statut d'état
non-membre mais observateur à la
palestine
comment vous regardez cette initiative
française est-ce qu'il a parlé au nom de
l'europe ou en son propre nom
celui dont il est certainement parlé en
son propre nom maintenant je ne veux pas
ridiculiser l'initiative du président
français
simplement il faut dire que d'abord elle
enfonce un tout petit peu avec tout le
respect que j'ai pour lui les portes
ouvertes parce que de toute façon elle
la palestine peut revenir à l'assemblée
générale et elle aura la majorité pour
avoir ce statut d'état non-membre non
membres mais et a tout de même et donc
ça c'est une question de majorité simple
ce que nicolas sarkozy voudrait faire
s'est entraîné toute l'europe à voter ça
mais sinon le statut ils l'auront avec
ou sans laurent pc vous entendez les
palestiens et se demander si l'europe ne
sait pas faire son unité
nous nous aurons la communauté
internationale la majorité là bas à
l'assemblée générale ce que contient
aussi cette initiative
c'est un élément qui pour nous est
inacceptable
nous parlementaires européens c'est à
dire ce qu on a dit ce qu'on a dit dans
les couloirs et je prends les
précautions
l'idée qu'il y aurait une sorte de
négociation sur la cour pénale
internationale
parce qu'un état non membre peut
appartenir à la cour pénale
internationale et y avoir accès et on
voudrait freiner palestine et à là
dessus nous disons c'est inacceptable la
cour pénale internationale d'un droit
d'un état nous poussons tous les états à
souscrire au statut de rome donc on peut
pas empêcher les palestiniens de pouvoir
allier de penser il ya des propositions
il ya des initiatives mais quelle chance
l'europe notamment le parlement européen
at-il d'être entendu par les
palestiniens par israël par les acteurs
de ce conflit alors dans une région où
même les états unis ont du mal à se
faire entendre du côté des délais des
israéliens c'est vrai que l'europe a
beaucoup de levier qu'elle n'a jamais
utilisé les clients d'arrosage d'élever
des leviers de pression et de pressions
économiques
je ne dis pas que c'est ce qu'il faut
utiliser pour le moment ce qu' il sera
elle utilise c'est la division
européenne parce que l'europe
elle a toujours dit que l avait une la
conviction qu'il fallait souvent des sur
le droit international c'est à dire une
solution à deux états sur les frontières
de 67 avec jérusalem comme capitale
étaient les colonies étaient illégales
donc la position européenne et les
clairs si la position européenne ce et
qui précisément kaki 10 1 c'est à la
fois le parlement et c'est à la fois le
conseil
ça va des rois aujourd'hui pourtant que
les européens sont divisés que ils sont
divisés sur la manière d'agir mes amis
d'israël
ils ne sont pas divisés sur la position
européenne la position européenne elle
été réitéré par exemple dans les
conclusions du conseil de décembre 1999
c'était très clair et en 2010 ceci et on
répète les colonies sont illégales
jérusalem est
il est illégal de l'occuper par une
colonisation et donc s'il n'est pas la
position européenne qui fait probable
alors justement vous allaitez pas
problème et pourtant on a du mal an
andres la voix de ceux de ce quartet
notamment de madame ashton qui est en
charge de la diplomatie
le quartet qui fait pas la position
européenne le cartel aussi les états
unis et les états unis et au sein de ce
quartet on a du mal à entendre qu'elles
allaient la voix américaine à cause des
relations très étroites avec israël est
prépondérante
est ce que nous européens y compris
madame ashton a de la peine à digérer
disons ça comme ça c'est la volte-face
américaine parce que quand obama a fait
peu après sa prise de législature quand
il a fait son fameux discours du caire
où disait au gel des colonies etc etc où
il a pris une position très forte
et puis que maintenant il revient là
dessus et qui non seulement il menace
d'un veto pour vous c'est un changement
de position parce que lui se justifie en
disant qu'il a toujours conditionné son
discours à la reprise des négociations
pour nous c'est une vraie volte-face
c'est une débandade c c'est pour moi une
très très grosse déception c'est dans la
ligne
c'est dans la ligne des autres
présidents américains c'est dans la
ligne 2
de bill clinton aussi qu'ils avaient
essayé quand david mais qui avait
empêché
rappelez-vous en 1999 arafat avait le
droit
d'après les accords d'oslo de présenter
la demande à l'onu et clinton et itélé
il veut dit surtout ne faites pas ça et
l'europe a emboîté le pas sur tout
l'espace à ce serait une catastrophe
fait les négociations de paix de camp
david
et puis échec et puis seconde anti fades
a donc on a l'impression de voir bégayer
l'histoire et c'est pour ça que le
parlement européen a voulu dire stop
maintenant on ne répète pas les erreurs
de 90 mhz et l'appel est bien entendu
merci beaucoup je vais la véronique de
keyser d'abord était notre invité alors
le sujet numéro un en europe c'est
toujours et encore la crise de la dette
qui est loin d'être résolue les
dernières nouvelles de la zone euro avec
ce happening des télévisions européennes
réalisé par aurélie d'afas trois ans
après le début de la crise économique le
sujet préoccupe toujours les européens à
commencer par ce journaliste belge la
rtbf qui ne cache pas son pessimisme
la crise dans la zone euro dominent
l'actualité dernier épisode en date la
dégradation de la note de la dette
italienne par une agence de notation
bien connu augmente encore le trouble et
creuse un peu plus la bim dans lequel
semble s'enfoncer l'europe toute entière
sur la bbc le ton est beaucoup plus
enthousiaste le plan de sauvegarde de la
zone euro est encore en discussion mais
ce commentateur nourrit déjà de grands
espoirs
heureusement que vous êtes assis là
parce que croyez le ou non et où nous
avons peut-être enflé un plan pour
stabiliser la crise de la zone euro
je pense qu'il est important de rappeler
que les leaders mondiaux continuent à
dire qu il n'y a pas de plan pour éviter
à la grèce de faire faillite mais nous
nous savons qu'en réalité les bases sont
jetées pour le permettre
en italie la dégradation de la note
économique du pays par standard and
poor's réveille les tensions la crise
économique tourne à la crise politique
l'opposition accuse le gouvernement je
lance un appel à la majorité si ça
continue l'italie finira comme la grèce
la majorité n'assume pas ses
responsabilités n'ont ni la personnalité
ni le programme ni les conditions pour
tuer un gouvernement et de
responsabilité nationale
voilà pour cette crise de la zone euro
qui n'en finit pas on va en parler avec
un journaliste italien david carretta
bonjour je vous êtes correspondant de la
radio radicale la radio nationale et
vous suivi des affaires européennes
depuis strasbourg et bruxelles alors
toute la presse européenne parle de ma
race de cataclysme de catastrophe c'est
un peu une ambiance de fin du monde en
europe
est-ce que vous avez vous aussi le
sentiment que que la fin de la zone euro
est proche
je sais pas ça dépend de beaucoup de
choses c'est vrai que aujourd'hui il ya
une crise grave
même monsieur barroso l'a reconnu dans
son discours sur l'état de l'union
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya une plutôt
un état de 18 millions dans l'union
européenne
cela évidemment rente ou solution à la
crise de la zone euro plus difficile
alors est ce que les dirigeants
européens en sont conscients pour vous
vous avez écouté le discours du
président de la commission européenne
qui était finalement assez assez
solennel mais est ce que au delà du fait
de constater que l'heure est grave comme
il l'a fait ce que pensait qu'il ya
vraiment une décision une volonté d'agir
pour sortir de cette crise
jeu de la part de la commission
peut-être mais ses propositions comme la
taxe tobin
les euros bonne donc ne vont pas être la
solution à la crise
le vrai problème aujourd'hui c'est dans
les gouvernements européens parce qu'il
ya des différences de vues qui sont très
importantes sur la gestion et la
solution de la crise l'allemagne
aujourd'hui à un repli nationaliste
la france a toujours sa politique
souverainiste qui est contraire à
l'esprit communautaire
les deux proposent un gouvernement
économique qui effraie par les
gouvernements nationaux et pas par
l'europe ça ce grand problème
le grand problème qui aggrave donc en
quelque sorte la crise d'aujourd'hui
nous dit c'est la division de cdd
européen alors même que la la gravité de
la crise impose imposerait de parler
d'une seule voix pourquoi est ce que
l'europe n'avait pas parlé dit souvent
parce que chacun sait ce que chaque pays
a ses intérêts l'allemagne ne veut pas
payer pour la grèce la france ne veut
pas que ces banques souffrent de pertes
parce qu'ils ont envie en russie en
grèce l'italie à ses problèmes
politiques internes et l'espagne aussi
chacun et pour soi en ce moment donc une
solution commune qui vaut pour l'intérêt
commun des européens pas seulement des
états n'est pas en vue alors que
l'europe tergiverse tarde à agir et des
marchés sanctionnent certains pays la
grèce mais aussi votre pays
l'italie est ce que vous pensez que
l'italie peut finir comme la grèce
puisque c'est totalement différent comme
situation l'italie est très différente
point de vue économique il ya des
éléments communs comme l'évasion fiscale
il ya surtout un problème de crédibilité
de la classe politique je parle pas
seulement de monsieur berlusconi qui a
un vrai problème mais je parle toute la
classe politique l'opposition aussi si
aujourd'hui l'opposition devrait aller
au pouvoir et l'aurait pas un programme
pour sortir de la crise actuelle que vit
l'italie donc ça implique plus de
responsabilités politiques
finalement c'est ce que méritent
absolument absolument c'est là où la
gauche la droite c'est même là les
syndicats qui ont fait une grève
générale contre l'austérité aujourd'hui
dans toute l'europe on a un problème de
dette publique parce qu'on a acheté le
consensus social en dépensant l'argent
de l'état on a trop dépensé
aujourd'hui il faut réduire le train de
vie des états c'est ça qui demande des
marchés mais c'est ça qui demande aussi
vite les gens les gens dans les rues qui
ont marre de payer des impôts pour
sauver des banques etc
et c'est l'urgence en europe merci
beaucoup david qu'un état d'avoir été
avec nous alors autre crise qui a secoué
les t on en parle la crise agricole les
agriculteurs de l'hexagone accuse les
producteurs espagnols de concurrence
déloyale
on en parle dans un instant avec josé
bové invités de nora hanadi mais d'abord
le reportage tourné dans le sud de la
france et en espagne près d'almeria il
est signé sandra carcéral
des agriculteurs de toute la france
venus dénoncer la concurrence européenne
dont ils se disent victimes depuis des
mois wesley exploitants dans le vaucluse
manifeste pour la première fois c'est la
mort de l'agriculture
c'est aujourd'hui qu'ils sont là dépend
dans son exploitation
on cultive la tomate depuis trois
générations quand ils arrivent en 2002
le chiffre d'affaires est déjà en baisse
pour nous produire un kilo de tomates
grappes ça nous coûte un euro 17 par
kilo produit est actuellement en et 20
78 centimes le kilo le prix n'a fait que
de quelques dégringolé ces derniers mois
contrairement aux céréales la culture de
la tomate n'est pas mécanisables une
grande partie du travail se fait donc à
la main toutes les fins qui ont poussé
depuis la plantation où la pentecôte et
15 cm âme à cette hauteur là où là on
est à peu près 10 mètres de longueur de
plantes
ça demande un entretien au niveau de
donc les feuillages la taille de
bouquets le ramassage une main-d'oeuvre
payer plus cher en france environ 10
euros de l'heure contre 5 euros 50 en
espagne soit presque deux fois plus
conséquence le coût de production double
lui aussi difficile dans ces conditions
d'être compétitif pour ne plus continuer
à vendre à perte ses agriculteurs
envisagent de ne plus produire de
tomates
si rien ne change
à mille kilomètres de là la région
d'alméria dans le sud de l'espagne
un ancien désert surnommée la californie
de l'europe
quarante mille hectares sous plastique
ici le soleil brille toute l'année sous
ses airs mûrissent même en hiver les
fruits et légumes qui remplissent les
supermarchés européens
la grande majorité des serres appartient
à des petits agriculteurs
francisco rodriguez est l'un d'eux toute
l'année ils embouchent de nombreux
salariés en majorité des étrangers
quand je fais mes comptes à la fin de la
saison je me rends bien compte que c'est
dans la main d'oeuvre que je dépense le
moins c'est plus gros frais vont dans
l'achat du plastique destinés à
entretenir ses serres il admet que sans
cette main d'oeuvre bon marché on ne
produirait pas autant dans la région
quand les premiers immigrés sont arrivés
il y a quelques années on leur a donné
du travail on leur faisait des papiers
maintenant il y en a trop qui veulent
travailler beaucoup trop il en arrive
tous les jours c'est au politique de
résoudre ce problème pas aux
agriculteurs
le soleil se lève sur et les rideaux
capital de l'agriculture intensive entre
6 et 8 heures chaque matin les immigrés
attendent par groupe au bord de la route
qu'une voiture s'arrête pour leur
proposer une embauche même pour une
seule journée
avec la crise les espagnols aussi charge
du travail travail
parmi ses ouvriers agricoles 80% d'entre
eux sont des marocains rejoints par des
bulgares et des roumains entrés
récemment dans lieux susanna est arrivé
de bulgarie avec son fils il y a trois
ans et je suis là parce que dans mon
pays on gagne très peu c'est vrai que
c'est un travail difficile
on souffre de la chaleur payer 5 euros
50 de l'heure elle se dit plutôt bien
lotis par rapport à certains
ce syndicaliste lui donnent raison selon
lui seuls 1% des agriculteurs payent
plus de 5 euros
le coup légal les autres employeurs sont
souvent en dessous certains vont jusqu'à
proposer 2 euros 50
quand les travailleurs immigrés commencé
à parler de leurs droits ils se font
très souvent renvoyés nous en recevons
chaque jour ici aux syndicats ce sont
des gens qui ont de l'ancienneté nous ça
travaille pour le même patron depuis
huit ans il cumule les contrats sans
être augmentée mais impossible dit il de
travailler ailleurs
il ya du racisme quand on cherche à
faire autre chose c'est toujours non
parce que le travail difficile c'est
pour les étrangers des bas salaires qui
pourrait encore diminuer
comment ça va les ventes en ce moment ça
dépend on négocie
emilio pérez redoute de voir arriver
plus d'importations marocaine ce serait
une menace directe pour sa coopérative
car au maroc on paye un euro de l'heure
on pourra acheter des produits encore
moins chère maison ne sera plus
compétitif les espagnols et l'europe en
général on souffrira beaucoup d'une
concurrence à l'autre aujourd'hui la
france demain l'espagne d'autant que
l'accord entre l'ue et le maroc pour
alléger les droits de douane pourrait
aboutir plus rapidement que
l'harmonisation européenne des régimes
sociaux réclamée par les agriculteurs
et voilà pour ce reportage accablant
réalisé par sandra cerqueira donc en
espagne entre-temps josé bové nous a
rejoints merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes donc président de la commission
agriculture de ce parlement vous avez
regardé avec une mine un petit peu
décontenancé ce reportage
quelle est votre première réaction on a
l'impression quand même que c'est un
petit peu le chien qui se mord la queue
on va jamais s'en sortir
les français souffrent de la concurrence
espagnole et à la fin de ce reportage on
voit cet agriculteur et bayal qui dit
mais maintenant on a la concurrence
marocaine en gros est ce que c'est un
manque de régulation est ce qu'on peut
véritablement se sortir de cette de
cette situation alors c'est vrai que
tout le secteur des fruits et légumes
est aujourd'hui en situation de crimée
crise grave puisque cet été en gros les
diminutions de prix ont été entre 21 et
40 5% en dessous du prix moyen des cinq
dernières années
donc on voit qu'il ya une crise globale
se sentent ici a eu qu'à quatre années
de crise alors est-ce donc on est dans
une situation qui s'empire à la fois
crise sur les volumes qui sont mis sur
le marché crise climatique puisque on a
eu une période très chaude en début
d'année ce qui fait que toute la
production était arrivé en même temps si
on harmonise part à la fois avec des
règles très claires pour retirer des
stocks de marché en indemnisant les
producteurs si on met pas des prix
planchers qui couvre les charges si on
harmonise pas les règles sociales entre
les pays
on n'arrivera à rien et la seule sansone
co-régulation c'est très clair il n'y a
pas de régulation sur l'offre et il n'y
a aucune harmonisation sociale entre les
pays intérieur et ça c'est un drame
depuis l'entrée de l'espagne et du
portugal c'est quelque chose qu'on avait
demandé qu'on mette à plat l'ensemble
des règles sociales
on peut pas avoir une telle distorsion
sur l'emploi en plus de toutes les
autres pressions économiques de taille
d'exploitation parce qu'effectivement on
se rend compte que le tarif horaire en
france est l'équivalent de 11 euros là
en espagne c'est salle corot 50 voire 2
euros 50
enfin à un moment est-ce que
l'agriculture française est condamné à
ne plus être compétitif du tout mais je
pense que c'est à la fois un problème
pointures françaises mais on voit bien
que l'agriculture espagnole et condamner
de la même manière on pourrait parler d'
italienne ou de la grèce 1 sur les
fruits et légumes parce qu'on trouve
toujours plus bon marché et le problème
c'est à qui profite le crime
si c'était les paysans marocains qui
avaient ce marché vous parlez donc de
cet accord qui sont constitution dans
dix-huit européenne et le maroc
d'alléger les trois etc et enfin qu'il
va y avoir plus de tomates qui vont
rentrer plus de tomates mais aussi
d'autres légumes et d'autres fruits sur
le marché européen à un coût plus bas ce
ne sont pas les producteurs espagnols
marocains qui sont les premiers
bénéficiaires ce sont des entreprises à
capitaux européens notamment français
qui exporte à ensemble plus de 50% de
ses tomates
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose de
tout at on voulait dire qu'en fait on
est en défaut la production marocaine
donc est racheté par ses caprices
c'est même pire que ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a deux entreprises une
qui est basée dans le
languedoc-roussillon une autre en
provence alpes côte d'azur qui sont les
entreprises françaises qui produisent au
maroc et qui bénéficient des nouveaux
accords qui seraient prévus entre le
maroc et l'union européenne
ça veut dire que les producteurs
marocains marocains vont être aussi
éliminé de la production que les petits
producteurs français où les petits
producteurs espagnols et l'eau si on
n'est pas claire sur les conditions sur
les prix qui sont offerts comment on
fixe des normes parce que demain si
c'est terminé au maroc ça va être ou
qu'on va produire après on va encore
descendre mais la sq ont été supprimés
ces destructions c'est l'histoire de la
mondialisation
c'est un moment vous ne ferez jamais
aussi compétitif à y aura toujours là
c'est le maroc demain ce sera la chine
ce sera la thaïlande section agriculture
on est au coeur du problème de
l'agriculture c'était à que
l'agriculture c'est pas un produit comme
un autre
tout le monde a besoin de manger pour
vivre or il faut la meilleure façon de
manger c'est la production locale
capable de nourrir sa propre population
si on veut laisser le marché au niveau
international on va affamés on va
chasser des paysans et on va affamés les
plus pauvres en ville puisqu'ils seront
dépendants du marché national on voit la
spéculation sur les produits
alimentaires aujourd'hui d'heure de la
fin
il faut des règles c'est pour ça que la
politique agricole commune et sa réforme
en 2013 est fondamentale mais il faut qu
à l'intec des règles clairement ce que
va demander clairement ce que vous
demandez c'est que l'union européenne
abandonne ce projet d'allégement de
douane pour le maroc et vous demander à
ce que il ya une concurrence plus fort
plus régulé au niveau européen
qu'est ce que vous demandez concrètement
lors très concrètement moi je suis le
rapporteur devant la commission du
commerce international de l'accord ue
maroc
donc dans ce cadre là moi je préconise
qu'on abandonne cet accord c'est un
mauvais accord il est mal négociée il va
contre l'intérêt de tous les producteurs
européens mais aussi marocains comme je
vous le disais il faut rediscuter
globalement au niveau de la méditerranée
comment on fait pour avoir une
solidarité réelle et pas une mise en
concurrence les plus pauvres entre eux
ça ça n'a pas de sens et puis il faut de
l'autre côté une autre jambe
c'est la politique agricole commune avec
des règles qui harmonise les productions
peut-être qu'il faut réduire les
surfaces
peut-être en tout cas il faut mieux par
exemple en tout cas il faut harmoniser
les revenus les salaires ça je crois que
la question du salaire et on attend les
11 euros en france l'âge de 50 ans les
charges sociales aussi doivent être
harmonisées au niveau européen mais pour
ça on peut harmoniser par le haut on
n'est pas toujours obligé de faire dans
un pays en crise comme l'espagne à ce
que les producteurs ont les moyens de
payer 11 euros fin de la question un
jour cela doit se négocier ça peut être
aussi dans le cadre de la pac des
compensations il faut construire cette
politique c'est pas du jour au lendemain
ça peut se construire sur la durée
j'imagine derrière c'est aussi les
distributeurs qui profitent de ces prix
bas
sauf qu'on est en temps de crise et
quand on se rend bien compte ya
d'ailleurs eu dernièrement 1
1 un sondage qui a montré que pour 83%
des français et donc j'imagine des
européens c'est quand même le prix qui
prévaut dans l'achat comment est ce que
vous allez pouvoir empêcher les la
grande distribution de tirer les prix
vers le bas est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut plafonner
c'est d'ailleurs une proposition du
parti communiste pour plafonner les prix
moi on a fait des sondages sera aux
zones de provence après sur marseille on
s'est rendu compte que les prix qui
étaient vendus dans des circuits courts
de vente directe producteur au
consommateur qui faisait des volumes
importants sur des milliers de familles
on arrivait à des prix pour le
consommateur 20% en dessous de ceux de
la grande distribution et qui
rémunérerait l'agriculteur parce que les
intermédiaires étaient supprimés ce qui
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on veut à faire
de la qualité mais la grande distri de
la quantité on peut arriver à encadrer
il faut faire pression
or aujourd'hui il ya une distorsion dans
les négociations absolument
invraisemblable entre d'un côté la
grande distribution et de côté les
producteurs les consommateurs sont
complètement laissés de côté
or aujourd'hui on leur fait bouffer des
prix des produits souvent qu'ils sont
pleins de pesticides importées alors
qu'on peut avoir des productions de
qualité local qui font vivre les
producteurs
bon bah écoutez on suivra ça de toute
façon merci beaucoup josé bové d'avoir
été avec nous on suivra donc les
négociations pour la pac qui doit entrer
en vigueur en 2013
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
nous avoir suivi donc pour cette
première émission depuis strasbourg
parlement européen on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles avec katia
gilbert et françois veut donner bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
bon